turning to Asia China launched a new
round of military exercises overnight
aimed at Taiwan dozens of warplanes
buzzed taiwan's airspace simulating a
potential attack to seize the island it
follows a visit by taiwan's president to
the United States where she met with
Congressional leaders Elizabeth Palmer
has reaction from Taiwan
in Taipei taiwan's capital and a city of
2.6 million people it was a
run-of-the-mill Monday morning Rush Hour
even though Chinese warships including
for the first time the aircraft carrier
Shandong were offshore conducting
military exercises and Chinese fighter
jets had flown into airspace claimed by
Taiwan but these drills were too far
away to be seen from the island so to
make the point that this is a rehearsal
for war China released video and an
animation of Island Targets on its hit
list but none of it seemed to phase the
Taiwanese taking a break on taipei's
network of cycle trails after all said
Diana Lee Chinese threats have waxed and
waned for decades we
live our life we have we also have other
challenges to face but these are
unusually tense times with two
superpowers facing off president Xi
Jinping has said he will use Force if
necessary to take over Taiwan and the
U.S is signaling more explicitly that it
would come to taiwan's defense
meanwhile taiwan's president Tsai inguin
was in the U.S openly calling for
Independence and to Jolie pan that's
playing with fire it makes you worry
that that will provoke China into
attacking yes
the current Chinese exercises in the
skies and on the sea are due to finish
today
do everyone's relief this realm was just
practice but there is still a potential
for war over Taiwan though at the moment
all sides insist they do want to avoid
it for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer
in Taipei